Republican senator James Lankford of
Oklahoma is on the Senate Intelligence
Committee and will be at today's hearing
also remember the Senate Homeland
Security Committee he joins us from
Capitol Hill Senate Lankford good
morning good morning to you
senator you're on the Senate
Intelligence Committee you're gonna hear
today from representatives of Silicon
Valley firms like Facebook and others
what do you think is necessary now to
stop what has happened in the past so
first thing has already happened
actually that is to be able to
acknowledge that the Russians and other
individuals are trying to get into our
information systems on social media and
to try to influence opinions on that
there were false statements that came
out for instance statements about you
could text this number to vote that you
don't have to go in to vote you can try
to text this number clearly that's
designed for voter suppression we had
individuals that we're trying to be able
to stir things up internationally we
want Facebook in Google and Twitter to
engage which they have and to say how do
they prevent a foreign actor from trying
to reach into the American system in
deter our own voting system but also
just our normal communication that's one
thing when an American disagrees with
another American is something entirely
different from someone outside reaches
in the United States trying to stir us
up they don't they've done enough these
companies well they are starting to do
more they've hired more staff they're
starting to look at where things are
coming from obviously they've shut down
some of the obvious things like the
buying ads with based on rubles out of
Russia but trying to isolate individual
accounts and seeing whether this is a
Russian troll farm that's trying to just
stir people up that that job is not
finished yet we think it can be and it's
something that they can do it's
something that we should not have to
step in and try to oversee a free speech
platform free speech platform should be
its own but it should also monitor
itself do you want to hear from the CEOs
on this matter I'm fine to be able to
hear from their attorneys and their
counsels at some point at some point
obviously the CEOs are accountable for
their company but at this point I'm fine
to be able to hear from their
representatives they should be bringing
the official word from the company and
to me that's sufficient at this point to
be able to help push back and say what
are you doing what's your reaction
because you sit on this and intelligence
committee and has its own investigation
to the mall or indictment that took
place yesterday so those indictments
that have come out starting on Monday
those those separate indictments are
something that we expected Robert
I do quite frankly there are individual
questions that are out there and they
need to be addressed can you tell us
what their life might be in terms of
links between Jews Becca stone and
terrorism yeah there's been a
long-standing connections from terrorism
obviously it's faced typically into
Russia towards terrorism in that region
but there's also been long-standing
relationships between several radical
Islamic groups and that in that region
as well so we're still determining and
trying to unwrap all of this in the days
ahead there's still a long way to go to
test social media communications where
there's direct communication or was this
inspired that's still being unwound
right now when the president says he
wants to ratchet up extreme vetting what
do you assume he means I assume that
he's trying to evaluate family
connections or any other kind terror
connections has been one of the most
difficult areas you may have an
individual that comes in with a clean
record but there's also family
connections of terrorism so you have to
be able to evaluate the whole of it
we've seen family members reach out to
other family members once they reached
Western countries so I would assume
that's what he means but obviously the
white house and good chance to speak out
to that well do you think extreme
vetting is a good idea under these
circumstances I think extreme vetting is
going on actually for a long time it's
something that even the Obama
administration stopped for a season and
said we've got to re-evaluate how we're
doing vetting and going through the
process the process is already about 18
months long sometimes it is a process
where you discover that we don't know
anything and so it's assumed to be good
rather than we know something positive
about it and part of the issue on
vetting is you try to evaluate do we
know something positive about an
individual know their background another
family or do you just say they're not on
a terror watch list so they must be okay
that that's the balance you have to run
senator the suspect we know is here with
a green card that he won apparently in
the lottery system which is popular
amongst is Becky can you talk about what
that means for the u.s. as far as safety
going forward in this lottery program
the lottery program has been evaluated
for years this is not something new on
it there are about 50,000 individuals
worldwide they just applied to getting
the green card lottery they don't bring
any special connection to the special
country or family member they just
applied now a lot of the smaller
countries or countries have a more
difficult time getting US citizenship
love it because they have the
opportunity to be able to do that it's
been something we've
for a long time to say we should really
have a system whether coming to the
United States with a certain skill that
the United States need needs rather than
just you're one of the 50,000
individuals worldwide that won the
lottery senator the Lankford thank you
so much for joining us thank you